Das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Sehr gerne, bitteschön.
Ja, bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Yilmaz Mehmet.
Yilmaz Mehmet.
Könnten Sie das langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja, mein Nachname ist Y-I-L-M-A-Z
und mein Vorname ist M-E-H-M-E-T.
Ok, danke, Herr Yilmaz.
Wie alt sind Sie? Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
47 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 18. November 1978.
1978, ok.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Yilmaz?
Ich bin 1,75 Meter groß.
Wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ich wiege ungefähr 78 Kilogramm.
78 Kilogramm, ok, danke.
So wie Informationen.
Was würdest du heute zu uns geben?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Herr Yilmaz?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich sehr, sehr starke Bauchschmerzen habe.
Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben.
Seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Also ich habe das ungefähr seit 13 bis 14 Stunden.
13, 14 Stunden?
Ja, das hat in der Nacht angefangen, heute Nacht.
Ok.
So gegen 12 Uhr.
Um 12 Uhr, ok, danke.
Und wo können Sie mir zeigen, wo genau die Schmerzen sind?
Also die sind im Oberbauch.
Oberbauch, ok.
Strahlen Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus, Herr Yilmaz?
Also ich habe die Schmerzen manchmal auch am Rücken.
Rücken, ok, wichtig zu wissen, danke.
Und sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgefretet?
Plötzlich.
Plötzlich, ok.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob diese Schmerzen dauerhaft oder verschwinden seitweise.
Dauerhaft oder verschwinden seitweise?
Ganz zeitdauer.
Ganz zeitdauer, ok.
Werden die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit stärker oder lassen sie nach?
Also wie gesagt seit 12 Stunden sind sie ungefähr gleich.
Gleich, ok, nicht eine Verschlimmerung.
Ok.
Ja, Herr Yilmaz, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeutet?
8.
8, oh, es sieht so aus, dass Sie...
... sehr starke Schmerzen haben.
Möchten Sie Schmerzmittel oder könnten Sie das bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ich habe sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ach so, ok.
Könnten Sie...
Haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Nein.
Gut zu wissen.
Ok, ich rufe die Krankenschwester, damit Sie ein Schmerzmittel bekommen.
Danke, vielen Dank.
Ja, Herr Yilmaz, könnten Sie mir diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Stechend, bohrend oder drückend oder...
Also das sind drückend und stechende Schmerzen.
Und mit Übelkeit und ich habe auch schon zweimal erbrochen.
Zweimal?
Ok, seit wann leiden Sie auch unter Übelkeit?
Die Nacht jetzt.
Die Nacht, ok.
Und Sie müssen sich zweimal übergeben.
Wie sagt das Erbrochen aus?
Also das, was ich gegessen habe, kam raus.
Ok, mit Essensreste.
Ja, klar.
Frau Herr Yilmaz, gibt es einen Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen oder für Ihre Beschwerden?
Haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Nein.
Ok.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie gestern oder...
Was haben Sie gestern gegessen?
Also ich habe gestern eigentlich nur Gemüse und Suppe getrunken.
Könnten Sie das wiederholen?
Ich habe Gemüse gegessen und Suppe getrunken.
Suppe, ok.
Könnte es sein, dass dieses Essen verbrochen war?
Ich denke nicht.
Also wir haben frisch gekocht.
Frisch gekocht.
Wichtig zu wissen.
Hat jemand in Ihrer Umgebung ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein.
Wichtig zu wissen.
Und Herr Yilmaz, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Nein, also ich habe die Schmerzen die ganze Zeit.
Aber Sie haben keine Verlinderung oder Verstärkung bemerkt?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Ok.
Herr Yilmaz, haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Also solche Schmerzen habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Das ist zum ersten Mal?
Zum ersten Mal so stark, ja.
Ok, danke.
Ich habe manchmal solche Schmerzen gehabt, aber die sind von selbst wieder weggegangen.
Selbst wieder weggegangen.
Ok.
Und haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen oder etwas ausprobiert?
Also ich habe jetzt die Nacht schon zwei Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Dagegen zwei Ibuprofen.
Haben diese zwei Ibuprofen dabei Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, aber ganz wenig nur.
Ganz wenig teilweise.
Wie war die Dosierung der Ibuprofen?
400 Milligramm.
Ich habe zwei Stück eingenommen.
Ok, aber aus medischen Senses sollten Sie nicht zwei Medikamente gleichzeitig eingenommen.
Oder ohne ausdichtes Rats sollten Sie nicht.
Ich nehme die auf der Kopfschmerzennummer ein.
Da helfen die mir ganz gut.
Zwei Stück auf einmal.
Aber ohne ausdichtes Rats sollten Sie nicht.
Bitte achten Sie darauf.
Ok.
Ok, das ist wichtig für Ihre Gesundheit.
Und ja, Herr Yemaz, haben Sie Fieberstülse, Nachtschweiß oder Kaltenschweiß?
Nein.
Eeeh.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen, Atemnot oder Herzrasen?
Brustschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Ich glaube schon, dass ich etwas Herzrasen habe.
Herzrasen.
Ja, weil ich Schmerzen habe.
Weil ja, kann sein.
Eeeh und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Oder haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches beim Wasserlassen bemerkt?
Gut zu wissen.
Und wie sieht es mit dem Stuhlgang aus?
Ist auch normal.
Normal, ok.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Yemaz?
Aktuell habe ich keinen Appetit.
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Ja, bis diesen Schmerzen.
Wie war es?
Alles gut.
Wir haben gestern noch super getrunken.
War alles gut.
Ok.
Ja, schön.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, eigentlich bin ich schon seit mehreren Jahren immer gleich vom Gewicht her.
Ja, gut.
Ja, und schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Schwierigkeiten an zu schlafen oder?
Heute habe ich nicht gut geschlafen wegen Schmerzen.
Aber ansonsten schlafe ich immer sehr gut.
Ok, das ist verständlich.
Natürlich, wenn man solche Schmerzen hat, kann man nicht gut schlafen.
Ok.
Ja, klar.
Herr Yemaz, gibt es in Ihrer Geschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Zum Beispiel chronische Erkrankungen.
Oh.
Keine bekannten Krankheiten.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
An Knie.
Knieoperation.
Meniskusoperation habe ich glaube ich vor 10 Jahren.
Vor 10 Jahren?
Könnten Sie wiederholen, was für eine Operation Sie hatten?
Meniskusoperation.
Meniskus, ok.
Rechts oder links?
Rechts.
Ok, das habe ich notiert.
Und vor 10.
War die Operation komplikationslos?
Ja, alles gut geklappt.
Gut.
Herr Yemaz, außer Ibuprofen, nur zweimalige angewendete Ibuprofen, nehmen Sie regelmäßig
oder bei Bedarf Medikamentei?
Nein, nur Ibuprofen bei Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe oft Kopfschmerzen.
Ok, nur Ibuprofen 400 mg bei Bedarf.
Genau.
Sie haben eben schon gesagt, dass Sie auch Kopfschmerzen haben.
Seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Oder wurde diese Kopfschmerzen diagnostiziert?
Nein, ich glaube das ist stressbedingt.
Stressbedingt.
Waren Sie deswegen bei Marz?
Nein, ich war nicht bei Marz.
Ok, vielleicht können Sie auch Ihren Hausarzt besuchen, um eine wichtige Diagnose
stellen und eine passende Behandlung zu planen.
Ok.
Herr Yemaz, sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unfertiglichkeiten bekannt?
Ich habe Allergien oder Fragen nach Medikamentallergien gefragt, aber ich würde gerne wissen, ob
Sie weitere Allergien oder Unfertiglichkeiten haben.
Nicht, dass mir bekannt wäre.
Gut.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben, Herr Yemaz?
Ich rauche sehr selten, manchmal nur.
Ein Feuillant oder zwei Sonderheiten.
Eine Zigarette, zwei Zigaretten, manchmal maximal.
Aber nicht jeden Tag.
Vielleicht dreimal im Jahr oder so.
Wie bitte?
Vielleicht dreimal im Jahr.
Dreimal im Jahr.
Vielleicht.
Ja, das ist schön, dass Sie zu wenig Zigaretten oder zu wenig rauchen.
Aber ich empfehle auf jeden Fall medizinisch, aus medizinischer Sicht, damit aufzuhören.
Bitte.
Ich komme gleich nicht los.
Es kann besser sein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Wie viel und wie oft?
Immer so ein Feierabendbier trinke ich.
Oh ja.
Wie viel?
Manchmal auch.
Also ja, so drei, vier Flaschen.
Drei, vier Flaschen Bier.
Wie oft?
Zum Beispiel pro Woche oder pro Monat meinen Sie?
Alle zwei Tage.
Ach so.
Das habe ich anders verstanden.
Alle zwei Tage.
Ja, das ist zu viel, Herr Yemaz.
Aber ich treffe ihn beruflich.
Ich muss runterkommen, wenn ich nach Hause komme.
Ja, das kann ich gut verstehen.
Ihre Situation ist natürlich nachvollziehbar.
Aber es gibt noch weitere Methoden, um mit Stress umzugehen.
Was denn zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel, ja, nach dem Gespräch kann ich einen Termin vereinbaren mit einer Spezialistin oder noch etwas kann sein.
Ja, können wir mal gucken, ob es hilft oder nicht hilft.
Okay.
Ja, also Herr Yemaz, routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben.
Also ich nehme keine harten Drogen ein, nein.
Gut zu hören. Danke für diese Informationen.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Weiß ich nicht.
Sie haben Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ich habe viel zu tun.
Haben Sie Stress auch zu Hause?
Nein, zu Hause habe ich keinen Stress.
Bei der Arbeit, gut.
Okay, waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Ja, ich habe noch einige Fragen zu Ihren Familien.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund oder?
Wir haben beide Bluthochdruck, beide Diabetes.
Beide.
Und, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, ja.
Ist er gesund oder hat er...
Ja, er ist gesund.
Gut, so wissen.
Ja, Frau Herr Yemaz, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich habe eine Freundin.
Freundin.
Leben Sie allein oder mit Ihrer Freundin?
Mit meiner Freundin.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Keine Kinder. Und was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Yemaz?
Ich bin Koch.
Koch. Okay, Herr Yemaz.
Ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Laut Ihren Beschwerden habe ich einen Verdacht auf eine Bauchspeicheldurusenentzündung.
Okay.
Ihre Beschwerden, die Sie mir erzählt oder erwähnt haben, passen dazu.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Deshalb müssen wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, um das zu bestätigen.
Zunächst werde ich Sie körperlich und ausführlich untersuchen.
Dann nehmen Sie etwas Blut für das Labor ab.
Danach werde ich eine KG schreiben, um mögliche Herzursachen auszuschließen.
Und darüber hinaus werde ich einen Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Das ist wichtig für uns, um eine richtige, genaue Diagnose zu stellen.
Sobald Ihre Ergebnisse voll liegen, beschiebe ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Haben Sie Fragen oder gibt es noch etwas, das Sie hinzufügen möchten?
Nein, danke schön. Ich hoffe, Sie können mir helfen.
Okay, ja, ich hoffe auch. Danke. Bitte warten Sie auf mich, ich komme gleich.
Alles klar.
Hat jemand noch weitere Fragen oder können wir als Erstes anfangen?
Vielleicht. Ich brauche ein paar.
Wir lassen Ihnen ein bisschen Zeit.
Vielen Dank.
Sind Ihnen ein Sodbrennen, Sarisaufstoss oder volle Gefühle aufgefallen?
Ich habe Sie nicht verstanden. Es tut mir leid.
Sind Ihnen ein Sodbrennen oder Sarisaufstoss oder volle Gefühle aufgefallen?
Ah, okay. Nein, alles in Ordnung gewesen. Kein Sodbrennen, kein voller Gefühle.
Ja, guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte diesen Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie Zeit? Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, bitte, gerne.
Okay. Es geht um Herrn Mehmet Yilmaz. Er ist 47 Jahre alt und geboren am 11.11.1978.
Er ist 1,75 Meter groß und wiegt 78 Kilogramm.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen seit 13 Stunden bestehender Oberbauchschmerzen.
Laut Aussage des Patienten sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in den Rücken ausgetragen sind.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen drückend und stechend.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 8 von 10.
Weil die Patienten solche starke Schmerzen hatten, musste ich das Anamnesigespräch unterbrechen,
damit sie ein Schmerzmittel bekommen konnten.
Ja, ähnliche Beschwerden hat der Patient nicht. Keine ähnliche Beschwerden hat der Patient.
Begleitend plagte er Übelkeit und zwei Mähliche Essenreste enthalten das Erbrechen.
Und ja, Vegetative Anamnestige, auch Entschuldigung, Herzrasen, Tachikardie.
Begleitend klagt er über Tachikardie, Übelkeit und Erbrechen, zwei Mähliche Erbrechen.
Vegetative Anamnestige ergab sich schmerzbedingter Insomnie.
Ja, weitere Vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Ja, die Vorerkrankung Anamnese und Allergie Anamnese war unauffällig.
Anoperationen ist eine rechtseitige, menschliche Operation bekannt.
Gegen ihre Kopfschmerzen nimmt er Ibuprofen 400 mg bei Bedarf ein.
Bei der Noxen Anamnese berichtete er über ein Zeltema-Rauchen Anamnese.
Er trinkte zu viel Alkohol.
Man kann sagen, er hat einen gelegentlichen Nikotinkonsum, aber einen regelmäßigen Alkoholkonsum.
Okay, ja, danke Herr Oberz. Und bei der Arbeit hat er Stress. Die Familienanamnese ergab...
Was machen wir denn heute?
Ja, ich komme gleich.
Ach so, warum?
Die Familienanamnese ergab arterielle Hypertonie und Diabetes mellitus type 2 bei beiden Eltern.
Und sozialanamnestisch ist er Koch, keine feste Beziehung, keine Kinder und leide ich.
Der hat eine Freundin, oder?
Ja, eine feste Beziehung mit einer Freundin.
Ich habe keine Vorstellung. Okay.
Okay, ja. Eine Beziehung mit ihrer Freundin.
Mit seiner.
Mit seiner, Entschuldigung, seiner Freundin, ja.
Okay.
Nach anamnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf eine akute Pancreatitis.
Dafür sprechen die sehr drückende, stechende und oberbauchschmerzige Mitausstrahlung in den Rücken.
Und Inapetens und Übelkeit und Erbrechen.
Und auch intensiver Alkoholkonsum.
Differenzial diagnostisch kommen eine Ulcosventriküle oder ein ACS in Betracht.
Genau.
Ja, um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Blut für das Labor abnehmen und mögliche Herzprobleme oder kardiale Ursache auszuschließen, sollte ein EKG geschrieben werden.
Und auch natürlich des Weiteren werde ich so ein Abdomen durchführen, so wie ein CT-Abdomen mit Kontrastmittel oder gegebenenfalls eine MRCP veranlassen.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Leber- und Nierenwerte, auch Cholestasparameter, Amylase, Lipase und
auch Lipidprofil und Urin und Urinstatus kontrollieren lassen.
Auch natürlich um eine mögliche Ursache auszuschließen, muss ich auch im Labor Herzensin kontrollieren lassen.
Auch in Stuhldiagnostik Elastase I ist auch wichtig, weil mein Verdachtdiagnos Akutpancreatitis ist.
Und auch Elektrolytin, entschuldigung, auch wichtig, besonders Calcium und Potassium.
Sie müssten glaube ich keinen Moment einer Stuhlprobe machen, weil eine Stuhlprobe dauert eh drei Tage, zwei Tage ungefähr in Deutschland.
Da können Sie eine Elastase nachweisen für eine Pancreasinsuffizienz.
Nicht für eine Entzündung normalerweise. Also für eine Entzündung machen Sie normalerweise keine Stuhlprobe.
Nur wenn Sie den Verdacht haben auf eine Pancreasinsuffizienz bei einer chronischen Pancreatitis, dann kann man das machen natürlich im Verlaufen.
Ich würde auch Blutzucker und Thermoglobin A1C kontrollieren lassen, weil der Patient über 45 Jahre alt und Alkoholkonsum und auch familiäre Belastung hat.
Was machen Sie denn therapeutisch? Wie helfen Sie diesen Patienten?
Sollte sich die Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich diese Patienten intensiv stationär aufnehmen, je nachdem, ob es gemein ist.
Als initiale Therapie würde ich Flüssigheitszufuhr und elektronische Substitution und auch Nahrungskarenz und symptomatisch Antimethikum analgetikum herordnen.
Warum Intensivstation?
Weil Pancreatitis eine Lebensbedrohung ist und schnell verschlimmende.
Was könnte passieren?
Was könnte passieren? Warum Intensivmedizin?
Engmächige Überwachung kann dieser Patientin wesentlich sein.
Wegen einer Sepsis oder weswegen?
Wegen einer Sepsis.
Die Komplikationen dieser Krankheit, egal ob es eine Sepsis oder nicht.
Allein um die Vitalparameter zu überwachen, um ihn zu stabilisieren.
Die Diagnose ist sehr gut gemacht.
Perfekt muss man sagen.